the Joe Rogan experience the place is
incredible
and we will have Clint and Duncan on the
podcast explain all that what's in that
little silver yeah so this is so one of
the things that we want to do with this
program again is you know first and
foremost is to protect the UFC athlete
protect the rights of clean athletes but
we also want to influence other sports
influenced anti-doping as a whole so you
sada came to us early this year and said
we've got some new technology what do
you guys think about using your program
to be the first to kind of roll it out
and so the answer was well is the
science good as it validated they said
yeah it is I was actually at a
conference midsummer back in New York
and sat on a panel with Major League
Baseball PGA Tour and the UFC and a
bunch of anti-doping scientists there
and they were talking about this
technology and the other leagues were
ass hey you guys going to institute that
and they're like nah you know I don't I
don't think enough there and they went
to me I'm like absolutely if you saw the
science tells me this this works we want
to be the first especially if it's more
convenient and more efficient for our
program so what this is is it's a
leeching device and you know until this
came out basically to get any blood
tests from [ __ ] you got some scissors I
yeah nice that was ready for you and
tell this came out basically any blood
test done from from our athlete had to
be done with a phlebotomist the full-on
needle in the vein take out a vial of
blood
so with this leeching device it's got 30
micro needles in it size about an
eyelash you put it up on your arm you
hit this button and painlessly the micro
needles reach into just the capillary so
just the blood at the top of the of the
skin and draw out a small amount of
blood and this this light turns red when
that blood is drawn out whoa the blood
is then deposited onto an index card
it's called dry blood spot testing so a
drop or two of blood on the four corners
the cards then sealed up placed in the
mail and sent to a
laboratory this is all have to be done
on video so that no well you have a it's
not the athlete here themselves you have
a collector doing that I mean that could
be the future where an athlete is doing
it themselves on FaceTime or something
exactly but but here are the benefits of
that hey and this is this is huge for me
I want to make things that's convenient
for our athletes as possible so you know
you talk to our roster and ask them
would you prefer big needle stuck in the
vein of your arm and a vial of blood
taken out versus a completely painless
you know leech of some blood from your
capillaries they're all gonna say
obviously this you talk about cost so
blood taken out of a vein in your arm
requires a phlebotomist so in those
cases where you sod is doing a blood
test they usually take a drug collection
officer and a phlebotomist to take out
of the blood to take out the blood I
mean that's that's a couple hundred
dollars there a vial of blood needs to
be cold shipped to the water
laboratories here you're talking about
dry blood on an index card that just
needs to be sealed up it becomes tamper
proof once it is and put in the mail for
fifty five cents
Wow so I think incredible efficiency
convenience to the athlete for our
program and again we want to lead and I
think you know when you talk about
mass's question regularly about local or
regional MMA show sang has is great what
you guys are doing for your program but
how much does this program cost you and
it is a multi-million dollar program a
year and they say hey we love to do
something like that but you know we
can't afford that something like this
where now you cut your costs down from
sending blood to you know from maybe
thousand dollars to you know maybe a
hundred dollars this device and one DCL
going to collect it out and put it on a
card I think it has some really great
implications animation for the UFC but
you know throughout the sport taisiya
thing sure that's pretty badass Wow Wow
incredible anything else we wrap this up
we're good yeah man I think I'm good
listen you guys do an amazing job I mean
it's just it's incredible the results
it's it's so cool to see the the results
on the biological passport that you get
you guys could show it in a chart and I
mean pretty much everyone agrees I mean
it's just it's really
change the nature of fighting it really
has it changed the sport it changed its
almost eliminated doping yeah I really
pulled you I really appreciate the
platform you have here literally every
fighter and campaign manager you know on
our roster watches this so to be able to
get in and talk about these things talk
about that new technology we just used
that actually I think Rose namajunas was
the first fighter that you saw to try
that out on so a senator attacks well
hey Rose I heard they they did the
leaching device and the blood the dried
blood spot test would you think she said
awesome didn't feel a thing and she said
my mind is blown by the technical far
technologies come here and that's a big
part of anti-doping and that deterrent
when you're now saying look at how the
technology is evolving here and you get
an athlete that thanks well you know I
think I can out with them or out
cat-and-mouse them they see [ __ ] like
this they're gonna thing and perceptions
almost as important as reality in a lot
of these occasions and they start seeing
things like this and that deterrent
factors built up I think higher and
higher yeah it seems like at one point
in time there was a race and the dopers
were just like one half-step ahead but
now it seems like it's even and with the
possibility of freezing your sample and
then looking towards it to the future
you're it's not it's not worth it yeah I
don't know if I call it even yet but
that gas is definitely narrowing and
you're you're affecting the the way that
dopers are doping these days I think you
know now the the you know micro dosing I
think is big and it's it's difficult to
catch micro dosing but you've altered
the behavior of the doper from taking
you know drugs really unabated to very
small amounts so the benefits aren't
going to be as great I think you got to
consider that a win for anti-doping I
think that gap continues to narrow and
when they micro dose like what would it
like say would that be like testosterone
or something like that testosterone EPO
probably the two most common very that's
a window you have of detection matter of
hours hours but you know again going
back to I think I might have told the
story last time I was on but the floyd
landis lance days they were manipulating
during the Tour de France an eight-hour
window so from 10 p.m. to 6 a.m. they
wouldn't test him during the tour the
thought was these guys are racing up the
side of the mountain for
five six hours a day we gotta let these
guys sleep and they figure it out hey if
we do something at 10:01 by 601 the
release of tester can come and be clear
so you know yeah that prospects always
out there that's why the UFC program
there's no limits on the test now right
it's just a bummer
in terms of their sleep sigh it is yeah
it's brutal but I think you know I think
most appreciate that that's that's the
price of you know clean sport and trying
to ensure would there be a way to change
that like would there be some sort of a
wearable device that would detect
changes in your body I've often thought
that about a wearable device that was
completely that collected everything
twenty-four hours a day that you peel it
off after a couple weeks and it's anis
tested yeah or give them the wearable
device so when they're sleeping so you
don't interrupt their sleep cycle so
10:00 p.m. to 8:00 a.m. or whatever it
is that you decide would be the window
that they need to sleep while they're
doing that they must have this device on
that detects any changes their
metabolism any changes in input and then
they can't eat while they're on yeah
believe me the anti-doping community is
always thinking about things I talked to
Travis tiger at the CEO of you saw uh
last week and he you know he made it
clear and that you saw it I think
dedicates three million dollars a year
grants toward research and anti-doping
things like that so I mean that bed race
is always going on and is always you
know continuing
[Applause]